and also discover this completely
unknown thing about islam which was this
man called muhammad
who i had been taught precisely nothing
about at school to learn about his his
life as sierra obviously hadith and so
on was uh quite extraordinary and those
it was shocking how ignorant i was and
how we generally are in the west you
know we learned about
julius caesar uh alexander the great but
no one is mentioning
muhammad and yet you know he he he
surpassed
he was he excelled in every area as a a
military leader as a general as a
head of state
as a father as a prophet as a spiritual
mystic almost um and so on and so on he
he he just excelled in so many areas
looking at it purely humanly here
um so whilst you can compare him to
individuals great individuals in history
they excel in any one area perhaps like
alexander the great was a great general
yeah
but mohammed was a great general too and
he was all these other things as well so
as an all-rounder interdisciplinary
genius um
he uh is pretty unique i don't know if
anyone else
historically who can match him
just on a purely human level i mean and
yet we don't read anything about him in
the west
except bad things perhaps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the dona the three muslims podcast
today we're joined with a very special
guest
brother blogging theology
paul williams
welcome
and thank you very much for having me on
your amazing channel
it's a yeah it's a pleasure to have you
here
the work you do masha'allah yeah
actually you're someone i've i've
actually been watching for a while now
something uh before even coming out to
the taoist scene uh so it's the pleasure
is mine
it's good to meet you actually all three
of you
i mean
so let's talk a little bit about dawah
in general dawah to uh non-muslims
how was your experience with all that
well what i do on blogging theology is
not really dower it's um
basically trying to raise the bar when
it comes to knowledge about the
abrahamic faith judaism christianity and
islam so
if
if along the way um you know that helps
to
give people more accurate knowledge
about islam particularly that's really
great um because there's a lot of mis
misunderstanding and uh fake news about
islam floating around and quite a bit of
fake news about christianity too uh to
be fair so um yeah so i do it by giving
a um i invite guests who some of whom
are um you know top of their field
academically uh professors and scholars
to talk about uh judaism or islam or
christianity and the bible and so on and
so i can learn from them and and by
extension other people who are
interested can learn as well hopefully
wow that's that's actually uh very
interesting very very interesting
so what what are some of the
misconceptions that you think are common
when it comes to like you know
christianity and stuff
that people might like
how long we got i would need several
days to go through them
i i don't know the uh the the west will
be you you know as well as better than
that you know there are many people in
the west in north america and in europe
you have
wrong ideas about islam being a
terrorist religion or um you know being
a religion
that doesn't honor jesus for example and
that there's nothing to do with jesus of
nazareth or moses
but also conversely with with
christianity there um
there are some misapprehensions about
what christianity is i think the main
one that the main
misconception i think that muslims many
muslims have is that they tend to think
that christianity is just one thing it's
just like a homogenous religion with a
similar set of doctrines and it's what
basically evangelicals believe really so
it's all focused on the bible and so on
but actually most christians today are
not like that they're catholics or
orthodox christians and they don't
really focus on the bible they focus on
the teaching of the church and they have
a different way of understanding the
scriptures anyway and so i think a lot
of christian sorry muslim apologetics
endower is focused on a minority group
within the christian church globally and
not the elephant in the room which is
which is actually a little bit different
i mean there is a huge overlap but there
is a different character to it and a
different focus within
most christians in the world and it's
not what we think of as evangelicals
believing it's a little bit different so
i think there's a misconception there
it's not a huge problem but it's just it
just needs to refocus it a bit
in
yeah so i mean it sounds like when it
comes to you know speaking with
christians conversing with christians we
shouldn't be quoting the bible as much
as we do perhaps
yes
i think that yes actually i mean for
some christians uh
quoting the bible is absolutely fine but
um
i mean when the quran for example tells
the the biblical stories it doesn't
it doesn't this is just my personal view
but it doesn't actually quote the bible
it's anyway or at least perhaps only in
one place it quotes a verse from the
psalm it says and the psalmist says but
nearly all of the time the quran is not
quoting the bible is talking about the
stories we find in the biblical
tradition like the story of moses or
joseph or jesus and so on
um especially moses particularly but it
tells them in its own way and uh
sometimes politically i think in
correcting
um
the uh the stories we see in the bible
so it's not really quoting the bible
it's saying well this is what really
happened you know you say this about
jesus or this about moses but this is
what really happened uh according to the
quran so
it has a different way of doing it but
perhaps yeah and of course the huge
emphasis on tao heed as well in the
in the quran uh the the the unique
oneness of god as opposed to the
freeness of god we see in much of
christianity
yeah
so you mentioned the elephant in the
room so i have to ask what exactly is
elephant in the room
well i i meant for um
muslim perceptions of christianity i
would say muslim these are muslims i
know i mean i don't know what muslims
perceptions are say in china or in south
america or something just talking about
the muslims i know
in that it seems to be focused on an
evangelical paradigm of what
christianity is so it's all about the
new testament the gospels it's about the
bible uh justification by faith is about
paul's theology particularly um very big
focus on that but that's quite different
from a more catholic understanding which
is focused on the teaching of the church
and the the magisterium and the pope
and the importance of saints uh
obviously the virgin mary uh and uh and
the mass as well and the idea of the uh
the presentness of jesus sacrifice in
the mass
um it's quite a different focus and um i
don't see so much um islamic kind of
critique of that
yeah
it's
you know
really um that's just my experience it
may not be true elsewhere though
yeah i mean now that i think about it
from everything i've observed and even
myself when i speak to christians a lot
of it is just like oh well you know
jesus said this to that or jesus didn't
explicitly say this is that calling the
bible and i find that it's not usually
very effective so i mean to me it does
make sense
because one thing is
here's an example of an important
difference um
what is the word of god for most
christians well evangelicals by the way
would say the bible the bible's the word
of god but for most christians i
catholics and the orthodox by which i
mean roman sorry russian orthodox greek
orthodox coptics and so on tradition
with a big t
is also called the word of god and the
second vatican council the catholic
church is explicit about this so the
word of god is found in the holy
scriptures and in the tradition of the
church what is that the creeds and the
councils of the church
and they teach infallibly according to
catholics and the orthodox the first
seven councils anyway uh the truth about
jesus and mary and so on and god
um
so
the word of god is not just the books of
the bible it's also the tradition with a
capital t of the church
so when you say where does it say in the
word of god that jesus came to be god
well they can point to nicaea and says
well nicea says he's god
and that is a catholic answer that makes
sense for them so you you know
does say openly in their in their uh
tradition in their word of god as they
call it i mean just do what i mean so
with an evangelical you wouldn't have
that answer you wouldn't point to the
councils in the creed you just say well
what does it say in john's gospel where
is it saying matthew or mark or luke
yeah
so okay so so would it then be more
beneficial i mean when let's say we're
dealing with catholics you know speaking
with catholics for example to speak
about their their doctrines and their
beliefs as a whole like how exactly does
it make sense uh like of this how do we
make sense of the sacrifice for all of
humanity you know can someone be a
murderer but believe in jesus and then
be forgiven would it be more would it
make more sense to address the doctrines
their beliefs
rather than
you know
god's word said this and that
i just give my own personal answer um
one of the most um come back to the
crony one of the most impressive one of
them at the surah is that one of my
favorite surahs is sir al icarus the
112th surah chapter of the quran
and um
it's amazing in arabic of course because
you can hear not so how it rhymes it's
all going to beautiful uh beautiful
rhetoric if you like but it might one of
my favorite english translations by
muhammad assad he translates it i've got
it up here on my screen here uh this is
the 112th surah this is an answer to
your question by the way i'm getting
there
say he is the one god god the eternal
the uncaused cause of all being
he begets not and neither is he begotten
and there is nothing that could be
compared with him
now for me is extraordinary because
when you look at this in more detail the
first verse there say he is the one god
seems to be a confirmation of the jewish
shema that's deuteronomy 6 4. hear o
israel the lord our god the lord is one
it's the same word
you know hebrew even sounds the same in
hebrew and arabic
um and it seems the the quran there is
universalizing uh the shema by just
dropping off
the reference to israel so here here is
he is the one god and then very
interestingly in verse three he begets
not neither is he begotten
there's an echo there of the nicene
creed which i just mentioned the idea of
it says the nicene creed uh that the son
is begotten
of the father
and the quran says he begets not this is
god and neither is he begotten
and for me this is a brilliant example
of what i call precision theology
decision theology and why it matters is
because jesus according to the christian
gospel in mark because the earliest
gospel was asked what is the greatest
commandment
according to mark and he actually
recited the shema deuteronomy 6 4. here
are israel which the quran is confirming
itself so the crop the quran is agreeing
with jesus
seemingly about the shema what is shema
this says the lord is one not three in
one not a trinity or person one alone so
this is an affirmation of tawheed
but also in in verse three as i've
already said it contains a critique uh
polemical refutation of
the word you know the word in the
catholic sense uh in the creed of nicaea
which does say he was begotten eternally
begotten of the father
so what it's doing here is taking sides
it's saying yes to g what jesus preached
and of course what jesus preached is
what moses preached in deuteronomy
is affirming judaism and jesus is in
that tradition and islam also is in that
same tradition and it's rejecting
the uh the later catholic
4th century understanding of
the son and the father being of the same
substance now this is brilliant
precision theology and um
so
in answer to your question a long way
around i i wouldn't go for me i mean
everyone could do what they wish but for
me um the heart of the matter
is
contained in this surah 112
the concept of god and the quran is
affirming tawheed which is
the very same
concept of god that jesus had which is a
very same concept of god that moses had
and thus all the jewish prophets
so i i would i would go there and say
look what did jesus teach about god
uh and and what did moses teach about
god and this is what the quran teaches
is affirming that is confirming that
but your church says something else
and perhaps we should look to
jesus himself
and moses
rather than later tradition uh in
centuries after jesus which which
actually doesn't confirm what jesus said
and what moses said
um so that that's kind of how i it's
just one way of doing it by the way so
it's
it's putting tau heed at the center of
a dialogue about um
between catholicism and
slash orthodoxy because together they
make up the vast majority of christians
in the world
eventually a small fraction of that
wow it's kind of long you know once one
time i'm gonna pass the mic to the
brothers here i don't want to hug it the
whole time insha'allah i'm just you know
very very curious here but uh one time
my brother did tell me you know um
so he'd refuse trinitarianism because i
was going to have a debate on it once
the guys kind of fought later but i was
going to discuss it with them and he the
brother told me tahit defeats
trinitarianism it refutes this just talk
about
and i thought like okay yeah you know it
makes sense one god versus three and one
it's a reputation but this just brought
it to a whole other level for me it's
like literally their their sayings word
by word the quran refutes it
refuses i must say i i can't take any
credit for this insight that this
insight has been noted so this um what
i've just mentioned i'm sure the muslim
scholars have noticed this but western
scholars uh are talking about this um
people like um
nikolai sinai professor oxford
he's written a book recently called a
historical critical introduction to kran
he notices this um and another chat
called neil robinson a prominent british
academic in um
in another uh dictionary of the crown he
mentions this uh angelico new worth
playing this prince pronounced her name
very very prominent probably the most
senior well-known um chronic scholar in
the west
she mentions this
that they notice that the quran is
polemically engaging christian theology
and reaffirming the shema
and so this is this is interesting
because you know many christians might
not appreciate quite how sophisticated
the quran is in its interaction
um with christianity it really is as i
say a very fine piece of precision
polemic
yeah yeah subhanallah
um sorry guys do you have anything to
add
i did
bro i just had two
off-handed questions man they're not
related but they've been on my mind so
one what is your favorite surah of the
quran unless it's class and then number
two what's your favorite hadith
oh gosh well
at the moment sir it classes because
we're talking about him but to be honest
i'm always changing my mind on that but
there's an embarrassment of riches there
so i think if i had to choose one it
would be the 112th
um the favorite hadith you know i i i
tend to read hadith every day and i i
draw most of them from this book the
book of hadith uh compiled by charles
guy eaton he was
an english revert
he was a muslim for over 50 years he
died just a few years ago he was a
british diplomat
um and the grand some people call him
the grandfather british islam anyway he
compiled this book of hadith um
and i i just um
shamelessly read from this because it's
so good
um
and um there's there's too many jewels
really to say i i like this jewel rather
than that jaw they're all jewels i mean
they're just amazing
so which one stuck out to you the most
by far
um well when i uh
when i whenever i come across new ones
you know that comes my new favorite i
don't really have one uh
particular favorite i i need to have a
look at them and remind myself that
they're they're all as i say is there's
too many too many amazing to say this
one is obviously my favorite favorite
and
it also depends on my mood and where i'm
at my life you know sometimes a hadith
may be more powerful to me than
at another time
so i can't really answer that question
yeah my favorite
i'd have to say is the one where
it's narrated that the prophet muhammad
sallallahu they were
enjoyed a good piece of chicken
i'm just playing i'm just like
i see as i say i don't remember that in
bukhari
it is
i don't know the source for it it is uh
i'm sure the prophet said that at some
point so wouldn't surprise me
so given that you were i'm assuming you
weren't born muslim
uh what was your first at least
interaction with islam was your first
ever introduction in your life
well i i before i came in contact with
actual muslims in my local mosque in
london i i was quite i was very
islamophobic so i i believe that um
islam was a terrorist religion you know
after 9 11 this is and
a danger to the west and um and so on
so um
whoops let me just switch that off
um
let me uh close that down so um
i decided um because i thought
sometimes i i knew that some sometimes
the media misrepresented the truth and i
was getting my information from
the usual suspects and i thought i'm
gonna go and talk to muslims to find out
what's really going on so i went to my
local mosque regents park mosque uh in
london
and met real muslims i was a christian
at the time and um
and so learned about islam and that was
quite a revelation and i um
it was discovery that the spiritual
depth that i saw in christianity the
spirituality
which was very important to me also
existed in islam as well it may sound
really naive thing to say but it really
was a revelation to me
and that
in many ways at the heart of
christianity
you see the same kinds of
concerns and and dynamics and
uh even concepts that you find in much
of christianity and in islam as well so
that commonality forced me to
reassess
my position towards islam and also
discover this completely unknown thing
about islam which was this man called
muhammad
who i had been taught precisely nothing
about at school
and
um so to learn about his his life is
sierra obviously hadith and so on was uh
quite extraordinary and those it was
shocking how ignorant i was and how we
generally are in the west you know we
learned about
julius caesar uh alexander the great who
conquered you know so many countries
he's called the great by the way even
though he conquered a lot of people or
we learned about you know here in france
napoleon is is it's french stamps new
stamps coming out now
with pictures of napoleon on i mean he
was a dictator i mean
um but no one is mentioning
muhammad and yet you know he he he
surpassed you know he was he excelled in
every area as a a military leader as a
general as a
head of state
as a father as a prophet as a spiritual
mystic almost um
and so on and so on he he just excelled
in so many areas looking at it purely
humanly here
so whilst you can compare him to
individuals great individuals in history
they excelled in any one area perhaps
like alexander the great was a great
general yeah
but mohammed was a great general too and
he was all these other things as well so
as an all-rounder interdisciplinary
genius um
he uh is pretty unique i don't know
anyone else historically who can match
him
just on a purely human level i mean and
yet we don't read anything about him in
the west except bad things perhaps
[Music]
so you say that once you started to
find out about the prophet muhammad
when
it was just kind of the turning point
for you and then you you kind of
started to dive in it even more and like
look into it more i i've always been
interested in
the the relationship between the
abrahamic faith so i i i've gone quite
deep into christianity academically and
as a practicing christian
and uh discovering islam that i wanted
to understand that so i had to i was a
lot of catching up to do so involved a
lot of reading and thinking and um
reassessing
um
and just as a an add-on to that it was
only
two or three years ago i think that i
even began to start looking at judaism
and you know as a as a christian as when
i was a christian you think are you you
know what judaism is it's the old
testament but that's not judaism that's
kind of a christian
take on things real judaism is something
else it's based on the uh the talmud and
the mission of the gemara and you know
rabbinic judaism is not the same as the
israelite uh faith that um
jesus knew about and i mean is much more
interesting and complicated so that was
the last thing i began to become
acquainted with um in the
three abrahamic phase so
and then of course the relationship
between the three of them fascinates me
historically theologically
uh the interconnectedness and the
political issues because
relations with jews now muslims and jews
is particularly awful but it didn't used
to be it used to be excellent well used
to be often times more often than not
very very good
uh the jews found
a home and they were allowed to prosper
um
in the muslim empire you know the
ottoman empire whatever
things are very different now since a
certain event in the 1940s she won't go
into but um
um so on every level uh i i've had to
reassess uh spiritually my own you know
was mohammed a prophet of god so i had
to ask you know that question forced
itself on me and i i came to the
conclusion um
a little bit reluctantly that he had to
be uh because if moses is a prophet of
god
muhammad is a prophet of god you know
that they're so similar really you can't
have moses not have muhammad there's no
difference they both they preach the
same thing they have a very very similar
kind of understanding of
uh human society and the role of the law
the divine law uh and so on and so on
emphasis on god and his mercy and his
oneness and so on and jesus reaffirms
that so
um
you know so yeah i came to uh understand
that he he was a prophet as well um as
well as all the other prophets
but the big thing to change for me was
uh
losing um
any belief that jesus was god or god
incarnate the second person in trinity
that's that was the hardest thing to go
um
and he did go i had to go
what
man i got a lot of questions so i'm
gonna try to like simplify it uh what
caused first off
this whole thing to go for you this
whole uh notion that
jesus was god
um
i think
i was a i remember in my teens
i met some christians and i went to the
church and i was spiritually hungry and
i went to a baptist church where i
became a christian
and they they preached and they still
preach a lovely story
uh the idea that god loves you so much
that he became a human being and died
for your sins it's a very romantic story
you know while the creator of the
universe loves me so much he would die
for me and then rise again on the third
day et cetera
so i was if you hear this preached by a
good preacher who's skilled with words
and you know he can emotionally connect
with the congregation and you know try
and get you to believe
and you can really afford you can fall
in love with this idea and people do
and you want to give your life to it so
you give your life to jesus
um
and so i found it very attractive at
once i mean initially i didn't believe
it but over time you i came to believe
it and so i became a born again
christian um
so it wasn't that i had in any way a
sophisticated concept of god or
understand the logical or rational
issues involved or understood anything
about the historical jesus who he really
was according to mainstream biblical
scholarship none of that
it was i was sold on an idea on a
romantic
story a legend
which is powerful i mean i say
millions and millions of people uh
embrace this idea
um
which is why they don't give it up so
easily if islam muslims come along why
should they they that they they
you know that their god died for them
you know i mean the fact that god
doesn't die and the god is immortal and
their bible says that and and why does
god have to die anyway he can he can
forgive people surely he's he's merciful
you know apart all these all these
responses are are valid but they don't
really
you you're in a in a an echo chamber
you're hearing the same things come back
to you from fellow christians
um and you become part of a fellowship
which can be very affirming and loving
and
uh you know you can have a great bond
there with other people which i did
um
and i still think that
80 percent of christianity is true
uh it's like an iceberg we don't see we
see the top 20 which muslims don't agree
with but most of it we muslims do agree
so you know what there is what they
believe in one god they believe in uh in
the beginning god created the heavens
and the earth they believe the day of
judgment heaven and hell they believe in
angels and demons they believe that
moses was sent by you know the list goes
on and on and on on you know and that's
what christians believe
uh overwhelmingly similar to muslims but
on certain key points concept of god
and the role of divine law in society
which they've kind of abandoned really
out of this kind of passionate love
affair with god they don't they feel
they no longer need
um
the sharia or the helicopter
which was abandoned pretty early on by
people like paul who decided
to abandon god's law
for a different kind of
living
there are some pretty important issues
like that of course
but what was it that caused you to
finally see that okay it it's just god
god is god jesus is not a god jesus was
a prophet a peace yeah
what what i did i i went to um
university as a full-time student at
london university to study theology
christianity it's called bachelor
divinity the degree um
the bible in christian theology and all
that
um when i when i entered the university
i was an evangelical christian and uh
and i was not prepared really for what
hit me because uh even though i was in a
nominally catholic college called um
heathrop it was a very old college party
university of london um
they taught a very secular kind of
hard-nosed um historical understanding
of the bible and uh
um
and to cut long story short i left i
didn't finish the degree because i was
asked to write a paper on the exodus but
i was told that we had to assume the
exit didn't happen
that it was purely a literary kind of
exercise and i thought nah nah nah this
is all wrong i'm not i'm not writing an
essay on the assumption x doesn't happen
um this is the exodus from you know the
israelites from egypt and moses and all
that and i kind of left thinking i left
thinking no
and the problem is i did learn some
things about jesus at university uh um
which i wasn't able to take on board as
well because i believed in the trinity
uh and the historical evidence suggests
suggests to virtually all scholars that
jesus himself did not think he was god
and that he himself considered himself
to be a prophet
and and possibly a messiah that's how
that's consensus of scholarship so when
i left there i um
to cut a long story short when i
encountered real islam
and realized that there was another way
of being right with god or having a
relationship with god that didn't
involve trinitarian christianity
i went back to
the scholarship that i couldn't really
handle them
on jesus i mean
and reread some of it
and
with an eye to being fearless
where did the evidence lead and these
these scholars overwhelm me are
christians by the way people like jimmy
dunn for example and others
and um
the evidence was quite clear that the
historical jesus far as we could tell
did not think that he was god
and you know that that is the the very
very likely fact of history
um
and if that's the case why do i know
better than jesus about who he is you
know i
so you know i kind of end up agreeing
with jesus
that makes sense
so
with that being said what do you think
the
alteration
occurred like what do you think the
message just kind of got misconstrued
and instead of
you know it being that jesus was a
prophet peace be upon him it now is that
jesus is god
that's a very good question i don't
think that was the original yeah an
excellent question and it's one that i
tried to
look into
i i think the way that most biblical
scholars now for the last 150 years have
answered that question which is one that
they've looked at
is
is the following
that jesus himself according to the best
evidence went around preaching
the kingdom of god that's what it looks
like in the gospels they're talking
about god's reign
people's lives uh how to
and and jesus taught his particular
interpretation of the jewish law
so there was a great emphasis on mercy
on niyat sincerity and there's the first
first hadith in bukhari brother um
and god's love
um rather than in a kind of um petty
legalism
which kind of alienated people from god
and great concern for the poor and all
of these themes are very islamic as well
of course
um but they're there in the earliest
evidence
so
jesus it seems
saw himself in the tradition of the
jewish prophets he was preaching a
purified understanding of the faith
based on sincerity
and and you know the good values of
faith love and mercy and song
okay
fast forward to say someone like paul
who's a major figure in the new
testament he never met jesus i know he
says he had a vision but he never met
the historical jesus what did he say
his faith was well his faith was based
in was a religion about jesus
so he put his faith in jesus as a dying
and rising savior so jesus for him died
on the cross for his sins and rose again
on the third day and through that death
and resurrection
paul himself or people in general can be
forgiven and reconciled to god and
that's the way to salvation
now
it it's an obvious point that these are
two different religions jesus didn't go
around preaching
his own death and resurrection and
salvation by believing in
him but that's what paul taught and that
is the paul's gospel and that is the
christian gospel that is believed today
so to really simplify it we have two
things we have the religion of jesus
and we have the religion about jesus
and that is the difference
so i think muslims
many muslims might argue that islam
confirms or reaffirms the religion of
jesus
but not the religion about jesus
that that in a sense is a fundamental
dichotomy that we see
at work here jesus didn't go around
preaching christianity it seems that he
had no intention of founding a new
religion he was a jew preaching to jews
about judaism
as a jewish prophet and did you still
find that in the gospels in matthew it
says you know i i've only been sent to
the lost sheep of the house of israel
has not been sent for us if we're
gentiles
and there's a very similar saying in the
quran where jesus only sent to the
israelites
but
long after that you know with paul and
the catholic church um you have a
gentile religion which is based on faith
in jesus as a dying and rising savior he
became divine uh he became a divine
figure and that nicer he was god
but jesus said jesus moved all the way
from being a prophet
to a god
in a couple of centuries um
and i suppose islam would be an attempt
to cut away from that and saying going
back to the the religion of jesus not
identically because islam of course
doesn't say become jews but it says with
the coming of the prophet um confirming
the truth of the previous revelations
but that there is a final statement for
all mankind about what
how we should follow god
so some some i think some of the jewish
laws are abrogated
um
on certain issues but fundamentally is
the same i think
[Music]
that's insane man
when you put it like that that's insane
must be a canadian way of saying you
agree with it i hope
i'm not canadian but uh
okay sorry i'm american so
yeah but
i do i agree with it and
i think what's crazy
is that when you go into these churches
and you know how you said they they're
preaching this
new thing they're preaching
something that's it's altered it's not
like the main message is not what's
supposed to be put across
it appeals
to the emotions it not even appeals i'd
say it also manipulates
the emotions because like you said you
have these preachers who have a way with
words and they have a presence when they
speak and then on top of that they have
that um they got that worship type music
going on in the background
yeah i can't even do this sound effects
like
like it makes it just like more
impactful like what they're saying but
if you were to strip all that away you
would put like a layman up there
speaking about it you
it wouldn't appeal to your emotions and
it's like a part of you will kind of
just be like
something's not right here
i i see yeah i think uh and you get that
in a much more rarified way in high
church catholic settings where you have
beautiful music you have bach or
palestrina or something play with a
choir and an organ and so on or you can
have something like a pop concert where
you uh
particularly in american mega churches
where they have guitars and drums and uh
and people really going for it it whips
up the emotions everyone gets really
excited and you think wow i can really
feel the presence of god but actually
what they're doing is it's a human
emotion because of the buzz of the place
it's like going to see a conflict you
know you well you know
it's it's all hyped up and you come away
feeling wow isn't christianity amazing
but what you've actually experienced is
a very human thing and
you compare that with um if you have
congregational prayer at a mosque
no music at all obviously
and uh depending on the time of day you
may only just hear the person who you
know the imam reciting
um so it's very sober
and it's very understated i mean
aesthetically and so you can really um
in your presence you can be there and
focus and not just be
you know taken up with the beat and the
music and the charisma the preacher who
if he's really good well like a good
salesman he's trying to sell you
something
you don't have any of that this just
didn't exist in islam
but as i'm trying to say there's a
reason why it doesn't exist in islam so
i think
there is a sense of it reminds me that
that hadith when um
i think it was in bukhari when um
uh but muhammad had a vision he was
offered a choice between milk and wine
and he chose milk to drink and not wine
and i think in that kind of
wine is
makes you inebriated it makes you
happy and all this but it's not real
it's chemically induced whereas milk is
just nutritious and healthy and
keeps you
you know
in a good place whereas wine can go off
into
you know so i think that there's a
difference between that even just in the
symbolism of wine and milk they're in
that hadith
it's nutritious and healthy for those
that aren't like those intolerant
yeah yeah
so
you had said that you it's very
interesting to you the uh similarities
and you said the similarity between
islam christianity and judaism so
what are these similarities that you
found aside from
the obvious
ones well the obvious ones are quite
quite a long list that's the point
there's a lot of obvious similarities um
just the ex the idea for example that
the universe is created by god it may
sound really trivial but it's not in the
history of religion look at hinduism or
pantheism or atheism or uh you know uh
the or the idea that all kind of
part of the universe and god maybe is a
bit beyond that uh panentheism
yeah but with in islam christianity
doesn't that there's a clear separation
between the creator and the creation so
god is a necessary being and we are
contingent beings
and and that and that conceptual clarity
is absolutely fundamental and also the
idea that life after death there will be
a day of judgment and uh and a reckoning
and the separation between
the people heaven and hell is also key
in all three abrahamic faiths
and also traditionally the the moral
code is the same
sexual morality for example
traditionally
uh christian sexual morality and jewish
um bahalika and islamic secular is
pretty much the same i mean there are
slight variations so
in the sharia uh polygamy is permitted
although it's quite rare for obvious
reasons um
and it's permitted in the bible uh
christians don't seem to realize this
it's legislated for in the in the bible
so it's not banned um so there are and
it's not being christianity now it's
monogamy so there are there's slight
differences but fundamentally in the
union of man and woman for example and
the idea that in the beginning god
created the heavens and the earth and he
made man male and female it says in
genesis 1
man and woman and as it says in in the
quran you know he created the man is not
like the male is not like the female
that this this um
simple
binary difference now this is really
controversial in our time in canada in
america and
france if you say that you can be
you can lose your job you could be
accused of hate crime really weird but
it's there in the dna of judaism and in
christianity and in islam in other words
it's there in the dna of the majority of
mankind because three together is most
of
most of our species
but the west now is attacking this
notion
and and enforcing a very different
understanding that there there is no
male and female
despite what god says in his word
um it's all kind of cultural it's all a
social construct and all that but the
the the flea face are agreed that
actually no we're made by god in two
fundamentally different forms male and
female
and that tells us and along with that
goes an emotional and psychological and
even spiritual difference in terms of
what we are as humans
but
modernity would say would attack that
does attack that
with really damaging consequences
different subject
[Music]
have you looked into other religions and
other spiritual practices
or just the abrahamics
um i once read a book on hinduism i
think it was teach yourself hinduism or
something and i read the whole book and
i still have no idea what hinduism
i'm a westerner if i was in india as an
indian religion basically i i would and
lived there and kind of
sucked up the atmosphere and perhaps it
would begin to make sense but i think
reading a book is not a great idea and
that's not what it's about but uh
um
so um
i think i've noticed that most religions
now and throughout history have
ultimately believed in one god
i mean even the quraish before the
prophet came they believed that there
was one god but they also believe there
are lots of intermediaries and other
things of course but at least they did
believe in one supreme god and so that
seems to be the norm in many african
religions it's the same apparently
and even in many forms of hinduism uh
some of them are unitarian in believing
in one god
i know it might not seem that way but
some
some forms of
you know hinduism are not polytheistic
in that sense um
that seems to be the default position of
mankind this belief in one god there's
often mixed up and associated with other
agencies and intermediaries and angelic
figures or lesser deities and whatnot um
and that's one of the points of the
quran isn't it about shirk about
polytheism
it reminds me two of um
roman mythology
greek mythology
yeah mythology there's always that
supreme
yes god there's always like that one
and it it kind of always brings me back
to this understanding like
we've been playing the telephone game
ever since the creation of time
and it's like the moment that the the
message gets altered it's it's game over
and then god moves on to the next person
or the next group of people to transmit
that message because
if you look at everything it it all has
too many similarities a discount to this
yeah
i mean one of the one of the fantastic
things uh it teaches in the quran it's
there in um
hadith is this concept of fitra
that the idea that there's is an innate
human disposition that we have as a
species to believe in the transcendent
believe in god need to worship him but
also a sense of justice right and wrong
and so on and even tamir who i'm very
very keen on
different subject but you know he really
elaborated uh this idea of the fitra and
his writings very helpfully uh took it
to the next level um
and i think we see that in the religions
we uh you know people instinctively
believe in god this is the natural
default position but it can become as
you say
messed up with all sorts of other
practices which
um
you know and that's one of the the logic
of islam is to try and
purify
that yeah and it's beautiful too how
in that certain part
i don't know which part it is if one of
you knows it by all means charming
but where
god says like today i have uh completed
my favor upon you and completed the
religion like the it means the entire
message has been transmitted
which i mean that's that's beautiful
and to what you were saying before about
the hinduism
quote me 100 on this i want you to look
into it as well as anyone else watching
this
but
in the beginning of hinduism if you look
at the the betas
it says there's only one god yeah yeah
it says there's only one god i even have
this friend two friends actually who are
hindu
and they said that like point
two percent
of like the actual people who are hindu
who claim to be hindu understand that
there is only one gun yeah
it's crazy
yeah
yeah right i know that right that rings
true
so speaking about the fitzroy and people
innately believing in you know one god
why is it that we live in a in a time
and a place where atheism is so like
popular nowadays and it seems almost as
if actually i'll just summarize it with
this video i saw video on tik tok and it
was like um basically you know someone
shared their opinion and then someone
stitched it and they shared their
opinion that um religion is just meant
to control people manipulate their minds
and people who follow religion in the
21st century are people who lack
critical thinking which i think is very
ironic since their entire video like
critical thinking it was such a vast
generalization of you know uh all the
religions and religious people so why do
you think we live in such a time where
atheism's like the the standard even
though it's really
ironic to be honest that they claim to
be intellectuals
uh yeah i i had a big misunderstanding
about this whole issue uh until a year
or so ago and i came across some
research done by the university of
oxford and i've done a video on this
earlier this year actually
and they wanted to investigate whether
or not the
the religious sense that people have
because most people in the world are
religious today
they want to investigate in a very kind
of objective scientific way if religion
was something intrinsic to our human
nature or something that children were
brainwashed into something you acquired
through
culture
parents priests whatever
and they came to the conclusion after
exhaustive research uh that uh
the religious instinct the sense of
religion is is intrinsic in the dna of
our species okay it's what it is to be
human we human beings would seem to be
uh we can't help being religious it's
what we what we're like
so the idea that atheism is a problem
that needs to be explained rather than
faith a religious sense seems to be
natural to our species
and then it came across another bit of
research much more recently five
universities in britain teamed together
and did some global research
into atheism atheists to find out what
they really believed and if you heard
this absolutely extraordinary research
the university of kenya the whole list i
did a video on this as well of course
it's such an interesting subject
and they found that the majority of
self-described atheists these are people
in japan in north america sorry in
europe south america
uh you know they picked some
representative countries around the
world for different population groups
and different faiths backgrounds
most atheists on earth
believe in the supernatural
what how can that be they believe
in angels they believe in life after
death
they say don't believe in god but these
you see when i think of when i used to
think of atheists i thought people like
rich dawkins the famous british
biologist who is a materialist
so he rejects god angels everything you
know he reduces all
phenomena in the universe to his
materialistic understanding of the world
but he's not typical of atheists you
would see most most atheists do believe
in the supernatural
uh and this would be whether it be
atheists in china or in finland or
whatever
so when we say about the rise of atheism
what are we talking about
for most atheists they do believe in
what the quran talks about
you know they just don't believe in god
now i have no idea why they don't
believe in god given they believe in
everything else i don't see what the
problem is but it's not that they're
materialists who reject the supernatural
no
a minority of atheists do most atheists
embrace the supernatural that was the
conclusion of this academic research
you can see online globally
so i think what we're looking at this
rise of atheism we're not really looking
at what most even atheists are about
we're talking about um the kind of
public
um attacks on religion that we see
particularly here in france for example
where the state routinely closes moths
down you say the wrong thing
and even when the catholic church says
the wrong thing they get put down so
it's a kind of an ideology which is a
militant secular ideology which forces
down faith
but ordinarily
if this if the researchers believe
atheists themselves more often than not
do believe
in the supernatural life after death
angels and demons
i mean i have no idea why you can
believe in angel demons why don't
believe in god just don't get it but
this is this is the case
um so my understanding of atheism until
i read that was wrong i thought atheists
were like richard dawkins most are not
and this is a problem that from the daoa
by the way i've ever christian
evangelism you're going around oh you're
an atheist so you don't believe in
anything do you well actually they may
well believe in a whole bunch of stuff
that even the quran teaches actually
isn't that amazing so i i
you know all people of faith have a much
easier time talking to atheists now
because they can perhaps assume a whole
bunch of stuff in common which you
wouldn't really get to
expect from the label atheist
yeah definitely news to me well it's
been long enough to look into that no
dude no it's it's uh i did a video on it
and i i was stunned it was it was
brought up the the news was mentioned in
new scientists in the british press and
it was like wow atheists tend to believe
in the supernatural i think
i didn't i really did not expect that
so i think what the problem is is
militant secularism um which is an
ideology which kind of floats above all
this you know
it is not that
people even atheist you see mankind is
overwhelmingly religious even atheists
in the main are religious in a sense if
they're religious if it means if you
believe in supernatural you believe in
angels i'd say you're religious
i'd say that
but you could call yourself an atheist
so that's how crazy this whole thing is
[Music]
subhanallah so i had a question so this
this uh
you sharing all these hadith every day
or at least regularly or sharing stuff
about islam do you believe that this
proclivity comes from fitra to an extent
what am i sharing i know so what do you
mean the tendency that i see in a lot of
uh muslim channels like they just love
giving dawah they just love sharing
stuff about the religion do you think
this this tendency comes from the fitra
well to be honest
my answer is very simple i i think there
are a lot of really really great hadith
and i i just think they're amazing
so i just
i like sharing really good stuff like i
enjoy it and i want to share it so
that's why i do it if the hadith were
crap
to be rude i wouldn't share
i just wouldn't bother you know what i
mean i share them because they're
amazing
um so it's a natural thing i just like
to share these things so these are
amazing sayings i mean you you do get
amazing sayings by the way in the bible
um
but it just so happens that there are so
many hadith and there's so
so many that are amazing that it's just
great to share them i also like sharing
ayah from the quran as well i don't do
that as much but i could do
um because
it's just really good to share this
stuff and people like it and we can all
enjoy it that's why i do it it's not
because i feel that i ought to share
hadith no
if as i say if they're death or rubbish
i wouldn't bother but they're not
they're amazing so it's a question of
hey folks have you heard this one have
you heard this one have you heard this
one
that's why i do it
mashallah so we we established that
there's an overwhelming at least
population that we neglect of atheists
that do believe in uh i guess pseudo
religiosity right
where would you where would you stem the
the cause of the people that don't even
believe in that the people that are like
okay i don't even believe in anything
and uh do you think it's an issue with
them submitting to god or at least
humiliating themselves because a trend i
see with a lot of these sad people is
they're very narcissistic on average and
they think like okay why would i submit
to god i'm better than that
this is a really really good question
and there's a even more more research uh
i did a video on this as well um what
they did was scientists i think it was
in the states
i i i'm hazing on the details i'm just
trying to recollect what was done
they did uh an experiment uh comparing a
group of atheists to a group of people
of faith
to see if they would respond in the same
way
when into a series of questions and i
think if i remember right here i wish i
prepared this in advance by the way it
would be more precise but uh this is
under scientific conditions so you ask a
you have a control group of atheists
control group of people of faith be they
christians or muslims or whatever
um
so uh
how did they respond biologically i mean
they were being tested it's not like
what did they say you could you could
take their blood pressure you could take
that pulse you could you could you could
analyze their physical responses to
various verbal stimuli so uh what so i
think again this is from memory and i
probably got this fairly crude it's a
fairly crude remembrance of this but
um so one question was how do you
respond uh to uh the idea of uh
your neighbor threatening you so your
your you know your neighbor they're
gonna threaten you how would you feel
about that because people feel bad about
that you know that someone could could
it hurt them
and then and everyone felt the same be
your atheist or believer another
question was
um how would you feel if uh if if you
were told that god would uh hurt god
would hurt you or god would send you to
hell how would you feel about that
now an atheist of course
shouldn't respond to that because it's
all
spaghetti monster it's all fiction it's
all myth
the believer when they'd heard that god
was going to send someone to hell or you
know that god was going to punish
someone
and it was true that they they would
they did react that it caused a reaction
it was something that meant something to
them
so what was the actual physical outcome
what did the scientists deduce the
scientists discovered that the atheist
actually also
despite what they think in their heads
they also reacted to the idea that god
would do something uh to to their loved
one or send them to hell or curse them
or something i forget the exact formula
but they also instinctively
felt that this was uh something they
could react to in other words they
reacted like people of faith
they couldn't help themselves
even though in their heads they didn't
believe any of it
so what does this show and it shows that
even atheists parkour materialist
atheists
still can't help but respond to
like believers do
when god is seen as something
threatening them or threatening their
loved one
you know
appearances can be deceptive
um someone can tell you i'm an atheist i
don't believe anything else uh and he
said to them well you know god's gonna
curse your mother the i don't believe in
god but deep down
that they do react
they they respond like people who do
believe in god they can't help
themselves that they in a fundamental
way react to this existential reality
this theological reality it's all i mean
i'm explaining it badly but i'm trying
to say that things are not always what
they seem on the surface
and again this is science this is
scientific research that was published
so basically people of faith and
atheists all react to god when a
threatening scenario involving god is
portrayed to them
uh even though atheists don't
acknowledge it openly they still
biologically physiologically emotionally
in their brains respond to it as if it
were real
even though they deny it they can't help
react to it
this is a scientific finding
so this tells us
to be rude for a second
that most atheists
are not really atheists they're fakes
because deep deep down they know the
truth
and science is showing this
this is not some kind of theological
insight this is a scientific
research showing this and i thought that
was absolutely extraordinary so i wonder
you know if richard dawkins you know he
was hooked up to a test like this and
you know someone said to him a scientist
says you know and how do you respond to
this you know and and god will curse
your mother or gobble and send your
mother to hell
and you know he would say
doesn't bother me i don't believe in god
but actually deep down he may be
troubled by that
like a believer would be
isn't that interesting yes
bro i just
i think that's mind-blowing and just
think about it for a second right
god says in the crime lust isn't the
crime
uh
you can't if if god chooses to lead
someone astray
there's nothing anyone can do to bring
them back right and it's as if they have
this veil covering them to where they
they can't see
they can't hear but that doesn't change
the fact that they are still a creation
from god
and the fact is that the the creation
from god has that fit to that innate
belief and even science is coming on
citizen hours ago humans are just
you can just be religious
yeah we're innately religious so even
these atheists who claim to be atheists
are aren't really atheists
so it's like man
even these people who are astray
because their own bodies betray them
their own their own blood pressure
pulse ideally the whole thing betrays
them they react like religious people
when confronted with a hostile god who
threatens them they react like even they
don't believe in this god their own
fitra still reacts
even though mentally they may not
believe it
and and that is a vindication of the
quran's teaching on the fitra actually a
scientific confirmation of the quran on
this subject
and it
it also
confirms the part where god says uh
whatever
bad you do like
it's on you like you're doing that to
yourself
you know like these people
they have literally
their body like you said their body is
uh going against them and their body is
in tune with the the truth
the reality of everything yeah their
intellect their mind may not be so
right so their mind is kind of like
acting like this veil
which is crazy if you actually get into
[Music]
um the new age stuff
the uh hinduism and stuff and they talk
about the awareness the consciousness
and all this stuff
well the main thing that they say here
is that
when you're thinking all the time
it's almost like a veil between you and
the present moment because it's like how
can you really be present having a
conversation with someone if you're in
your head thinking about something well
now revert it to this
you have an atheist who's like thinking
all these different beliefs in their
head
and like that's acting like this veil
but that doesn't change the reality
and their body is showing that reality
it's kind of love
and this is how in many ways science
confirms religion actually in ways which
are not generally known
um you know whether it be about the
design of the universe and exquisite
fine-tuning and the incredible
engineering of biological machines you
see in cells and the dna and the
information i mean
so many examples now of what i call
intelligent design in the universe at a
massive macro level and they're very
very small level
and in ourselves and examples i've just
given you with the science uh about that
um the indications the the i add the
signs are there
if you want to see them and i like what
you just said about being present about
seeing them not having
you know the filter of uh these words
and ideas floating around in your mind
if you're just present to it it's
obvious um
so being mindful is is a key to seeing
reality i guess
this is like
absolutely amazing because i've been
last few minutes and it's kind of a lot
like
every if you think about every single
prophet who was sent to their people
what did they say they warned them
about you know worship one god alone or
you'll face the punishment of allah
so if you think about it the reason why
this is the message and once they deny
that they're they're fought and they're
punished is because their body always
reacts to it so they always respond to
it but they don't always you know accept
and act upon it so like on that day of
judgment the body's gonna remember that
it had that reaction right exactly
you know i know it says that doesn't it
somewhere i forget exactly whether our
bodies will be a witness uh against us
but that's also true in this life that
you know according to the science you
know you can you can read the atheists
he's responding like a believer here to
these these one statement about you know
god will curse your mother why should
that matter to you
yeah
you're an unbeliever but you still react
like a believer
it's it's uh extraordinary
finding
and that was a mainstream academic
survey uh you know available as you can
see online um
and it's very high level academic
research and lots of uh detail to it
lots of analysis
um i just wish it was more widely known
but um yeah
yeah that well
i'm really really glad you shared it now
everyone watching and shout out luck and
hear about it share this video share it
with someone because it's very important
and you know i want to before we end i
want to tie this into another point that
i was actually talking a few people
recently about the fact that we don't
talk about hell
we live in a very like
you know
pleasurable society in terms of that
everyone's just going for what pleases
them so talking about hell is like you
know it's a bit taboo so everyone you
know even muslims i was like you know
talk about jannah talk about heaven god
you know will reward you if you do good
to reward you don't talk about well if
you do bad he's gonna punish you he will
throw you in hell and you will be
punished and he won't even uh speak to
you after that you'll call out to him
and the angels will will respond not
allah
and it's it's so evident that no we need
to talk about it because jannah and
janna are mentioned the same number of
times in the quran allah mentioned from
the exact same number of times this is
true
because we respond to both we respond to
the the doing good getting rewarded but
we also respond to doing bad and getting
punished and this you know um
research shows that as muslims at least
we need to also tell people that listen
if you don't go on the right path you
will go to hell and even people that
cosmic skeptic you know once in a while
become scared of the idea of going to
hell and that you know speaks i think
very loudly
no absolutely absolutely
and bro it's not fear-mongering to say
so before any atheist god on us for that
it's not it's just it is what it is it's
fact yeah i mean think about it if if an
army was coming to like invade canada
and i'm warning everyone they're going
to say are you fear-mongering no like
there's a threat it's only
fear-mongering when there's no real
threat
yeah it's a healthy fear it's a wise
fear based on realities it's not just uh
can people say oh why are you
threatening me like that well yeah if it
was just a negative you know but this is
real and it it's a healthy fear to have
that it's based on wisdom and
understanding not not on kind of you
know just being nasty
what would you say yeah yeah this
reminds me of uh when angel was reading
the quran and
he uh he was reading about noah islam
and how he was warning everyone
and just subhanallah most people just
don't want to listen
yeah yeah
um and you know the the best part about
i think i feel like the chariot on top
when it comes to islam
is
this believing it will only lead to a
bad life and a bad hereafter
and believing in it will only lead to a
good life and a good hereafter it's like
god is rewarding you for treating
yourself well and god is punishing you
for treating yourself poorly and i think
at the end of the day like if you when
you put it like that a lot like it
even
to death ears
it'll sound nice i mean nobody's gonna
believe in it but
it's kind of like it's it's
that's beautiful in my opinion beautiful
pokemon
all right well paul jacqueline thank you
so much for uh your time it was a real
episode it was a lot of things that i
learned that i didn't know i needed
and uh may allah reward you
well thank you very much for having me
it's been a great great pleasure and
honor to be on your show so thank you
very much indeed
until next
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing stocks shares
bonds you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mothers being a good
mother best conditions and behind the
mic hamza andreas zorces we will go in
with our final three with brother
angel
inshallah it's not just a responsibility
on you it's responsibility on all the
children especially your father in our
private area is very elastic and yeah if
you go too fast the skin will literally
crease up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]